i'm just excited for a new outfit i
really really enjoy
like people reinterpreting who i am if
that makes sense
fashion for me is something i take a lot
of pride in
i dress more sharply and so i would like
to break out of that
i roll out of bed like 30 minutes before
i
start work i can picture nick in my mind
and i can picture clothes he's worn
but i don't know if i have if i ever had
an opinion about stuff he's wearing i
you know i put myself together and it
looks halfway decent i want to find like
a
fun patterned collared shirt
more like 80s and 90s i think her
wardrobe is just a little bit more like
daring
and like abrasive than mine is and i
really like that though i mean
i have no idea what that girl is gonna
put me in this is how much i know about
fashion i'm like i'll put nick in a
shirt
and pants oh it's gonna be great i
straight up have never shopped
for a guy in my life ever so we'll see
i didn't know where to start there's so
many options here that when you first
are sent out it's very very scary i like
had like a couple of like mini like
panic attacks these are pretty cute even
though i don't dress the same way as
say jasmine does like i can tell that
she has an eye for like color and style
i was going for like a
street vibe meets a like zack morris
vibe
i really want swooshy pants or should i
have them looking like missy elliot
i feel like i only notice clothes if
they like are super flashy
or are like obviously meant to like be
silly or bad
tiger's our intern tiger do you think
this looks cool
would you wear it be honest a little bit
too
i'm not asking you any more questions
you're clearly out to sabotage me
in order to be street styled correctly
you need a dope
jacket wow i think if i with this jacket
and this blue
i think this actually looks really nice
don't [ __ ] it up i
i will probably i just hope it looks
halfway decent this is
i don't know how to shop for myself i
certainly don't know how to shop for a
man i'm excited i get to do this like i
used to walk around stores and like put
outfits together and hope someone would
pick them up
i kind of don't mind shirts like these
because they're so wrong
i guess what makes me feel insecure
about this is i feel like if i do a bad
job everyone will make fun of me i just
need to do something like big
because this kind of matches with these
i think this is like
a perfect shoe to go with this outfit
because the outfit in itself
is a little bit darker colored not super
flashy i think this adds like just the
right amount of glam and i think nick is
ready to go out and solve a mystery
a murder mystery in the outfit i got him
i'm excited for it i'd wear it we're
gonna go back to the office and try all
our stuff on
can't you can't pose like that what the
[ __ ]
is this it's some damn clown
shoes
is this is this what you wanted not
completely
tie this around your waist oh i now i
now i get it
oh my gosh look at him if i
was a straight woman or a gay man i'd be
like
what's up look at all those patterns
i'm like a fashionable background extra
for safe by the bow there we go
i never thought that i would be able to
pull off thrift store chic i'm really
really happy with all i got and i also
feel like
he's always very put together i think
this will help him
step out of his style into a style
that's a little bit more like
carefree and just like whatever i'm just
hoping that like
the great outfit that she's picked for
me will inspire me to continue
dressing like that and like going off of
that more it was a damn mess i mean a
trench coat really
who wears trench coats who wears polka
dots with other sorts of
patterns i just i can't i guess it
wasn't
up to his style and i wouldn't want to
force somebody to wear something they
don't like
so i will be okay if nick doesn't wear
the outfit again